pour les fêtes de noël louis de funès
travail
et oui il tourne l'avare un film réalisé
par jean giroud film dont la sortie est
prévue au printemps prochain
et en guise de cadeau de noël voici en
exclusivité pour tf1 un extrait d'une
scène que louis de funès vient de
tourner c'est du grand de funès et je
vais vous la proposer à ma famille il
est facile ça et voilà monsieur à qui
ils font de parler d'autre chose
même poussé pour moi tes points je suis
homme mal vous croise canaliser et les
choses iront dans la douceur monsieur de
vos soupers il faut d'ici moins chers
amis ne rien cacher la vôtre mais moi
monsieur je montrerai que je sais pas et
je voudrais du mieux qu'ils impossible
mais ce n'est pas là la si je ne fais
pas aussi bonne chère que je voudrais
c'est la faute de monsieur letra sein
d'un team à rogner les ailes avec les
ciseaux de son économie s'agit d'autre
chose que de soucis mais je veux que tu
me donne des nouvelles de mon combat
alors vous avez de l'argent oui je vais
t'apprendre check in mono je vois ça
mine qu'il est honnête homme et que sans
ce fait remettre en prison il vous
découvrir à ce que vous voulez savoir
oui mon ami si vous nous confesser la
chose il vous sera fait aucun mal et
vous serez récompensé comme il faut pas
votre m on lui a pris aujourd'hui son
argent et il n'est pas que vous le
sachiez
quelques nouvelles de cette affaire nous
voici justement ce qu'il me faut pour me
venger de me très tentant depuis que
s'est empressé ans il est le favori
on n'écoute que ses conseils et j'ai
aussi sur le coeur les coups de bâton
tantôt qu'est-ce que tu heineken a gagné
le faire il s'apprête à vous contenter
et je vous ai bien dit qu'ils étaient
tous les tomes monsieur si vous voulez
que je vous dise les choses
je crois que c'est votre
monsieur la tendance floue 8 me paraît
si fidèle à lui même
je crois que c'est lui qui vous a dérobé
et sur quoi le crois que sur quoi je le
croise sur ce que je crois mais il est
nécessaire de tenir les indices que vous
avez là que vu rôder autour du lieu où
j'avais mis mon argent puisse vraiment
vous est il votre argent jardin
justement j'ai du retard et en quoi
est-ce que cet argent était dans cette
voie là faire je lui ai vu une cassette
là que cette commune qu'elle fait déjà
la vienne
comment les fêtes allez belle est faite
à l'effet télé fait l effet comme une
cassette cela s'entend mais est payé là
un peu pour voir c'est une grande
classique non celle qu'on m'a volé oui
le petit si on ne peut prendre que moi
mais sa plus grande pour ce qu'elle
contenait et de quelle couleur est elle
de quelle couleur oui elle est de
couleur du tube d'une certaine couleur
ne seriez vous mettez à dire non est née
tel pack rouge et grise et midi où je
sais ce que je voulais dire si je suis
ici à dijon mais ces nouveaux bus jurer
de rien je crois presque je suis homme à
me faut lui en cette nuit de noël
il fait plus tôt